hello and welcome to this video when
playing Tom 2165 yeah and I need to win
this right below to five not what I want
okay
yeah age five why not I have made tons
of mistakes yet so you can push the edge
con
I will it is some yeah it is slightly
off him to do that but there are many
cases nowadays where early H pawn pushes
some work there's a line against the
groom felt where this is in fact
surprisingly okay but first do you think
okay this is complete nonsense but it
actually is not too bad and actually
here and he could have played aged form
which yeah would have been interesting
yeah we have a reversed reverse Benoni
type of position some things are a
little bit odd the age for now after
years castled is odd and yeah this is
tough to understand why am I not winning
if I for nothing hmm probably on b5 his
intention is to go f5 and I still don't
believe it should work now 5s only move
otherwise I just take e5 and you can
basically kick it in
okay okay we have five I would have just
withdrawn and I think
should win but still okay now here I can
take six or not take G six takes a one
yeah it's certainly okay huh if he takes
a one now or I can take a Dilys I can
take f 8 in German yeah that's what I
should do
yeah yeah I thought I just move the rook
of course but where int 1 there is
screen 85 check probably be one yeah
night yeah this is a check but it's not
a big thing in 92 it's not terrible
would probably just go here
yeah maybe you can soup like we take say
three I'm just going to trade Quincy
this just seemed simpler way to play my
king position was a little bit odd so I
think it's easier to play without Queens
now I get the King to g2 and should win
easily the simple simplest way to do
this should be if possible sacrifice the
exchange on a7 to get the pawns going so
King G to look m1 Luke a two and then
sacrifice on a7 if he allows it that
would be excellent
[Music]
the officer draw what what the heck man
just completely winning for wider
dispersion not even difficult to do by
Kenji - okay one he has some no real
targets for his books
I mean rook a to by the way in the move
before because I wanted to stop a six
just to make sure that he cannot get rid
of the pawn
okay this idea with the exchange
sacrifice on a six of course he stopped
it covers it twice but I can still try
to get to c6
the idiom and now probably just get the
King get the King over king of to know
it doesn't really have anything I was
thinking maybe there's an exchange
sacrifice or something yeah you have to
check the the desperate massive measures
because anything normal is just an
automatic win also I'm going to move the
King over to before okay now if I'm what
is the best way to do this if I go King
before he has Bishop c5 check
okay maybe I have to use the ephah as
well
yes to stop c5 I don't see anything else
so now I can get on to the e-file I
didn't even see that he can take now all
this is sir
not exactly what I wanted okay Bishop c4
this route is 6
yes defending as well I really thought
it would be super easy to win and it
isn't
mmm-hmm ever take it no yeah that should
wind ya there no I'm promoting I
couldn't he couldn't stop it completely
oh I didn't see that this is was an idea
yeah it was there was just more
resistance than I thought I thought I
wish is very easy to win but it wasn't
yeah h5 is a bit early especially when
the centre is not yet defined and I
mentioned this Greenfeld you know what
I'm just I'm just too sure what I'm
talking about
in the gloom felt this is actually
somewhat respectable line nowadays and
it's it's equal probably if black is
precise but if he is not he has some
some trouble but this is a little bit
early because now I haven't even played
defined it he have not defined my center
and I don't think that in a Benoni age 5
makes much sense so deform and mommy I'm
not sure Bishop g5 the engine really
dislike this move because of 97 yeah I
don't know I mean this just felt all
quite normal and now I don't like what I
didn't did here now taking on f6 was a
bad idea
I mean generally speaking taking on f6
is not a bad idea but here it is because
if we look at this now we had aged form
and I think you should be happy to take
this opportunity I mean if you have
played Age 5 you should should do this
I mean steady cancelled I think it would
be better would have been better if I
played this and then yeah played Bishop
f6 at a more appropriate moment
he is strangely enough castles which
doesn't make much sense out of age form
and I thought he I would be fine but he
played Bishop g6 and this is shouldn't
we already be five and no I thought f5
was the best chance after which I go
back and then I thought II four and this
felt murky at least take something like
that was what I was thinking and I
couldn't believe that black is fine
because of this weird structure Knight
a5 looked looked even worse and I didn't
quite prove it so this this one check
probably it is best not to trade Queens
possible I was just thinking that after
the Queen trade I'm just comfortably
better and don't have to very much and
let's see - and I see one is actually a
move
surprising then I'm not better after
that with blacks bed structure the great
night yet only four but it seems that I
have no convenient way to cover the pond
if I go here then the a porn is running
that's tough to analyze our black is not
with our chances for sure and that is a
lot worse yeah and this is a completely
winning position which I did not play
well I have to admit I'm quite happy up
to this point but then I must have done
something wrong
getting the King over looks okay I mean
get yeah and probably from here I'm
doing things that are not right maybe
this one I did not really see that after
the check that there is a trade on a six
and that is helping black enormous slave
oh yeah I don't know I said student win
I mean I really six now
should have moved the rook just here it
might still be a win but okay five Jim
it was certainly better before and here
he allowed this caption now I think I'm
getting to enter here here or will be
seven and I think it should win okay
guys thanks for watching